the chippendales they now have a photo
booth where fans can take pictures and
interact with the guys jillian is out
there with a preview hey girl
hey mercedes and rockies you guys know
wherever the chippendales are i tend to
find them we're here out at the link
promenade at their new photo booth set
up and yes they do perform at the rio
nightly but they're spreading the love
on the las vegas strip so i'm here with
ryan john john we got the whole gang out
here ryan how cool is it to you know
expand the chippendale's love here at
the promenade man it's so fun to be out
here promoting the show you know we uh
we've been at the rio for over 20 years
now and we love our time there we love
uh our theater there but it's fun to get
on the strip and and get to meet the
people walking around down here and say
hi and promote the show in a whole
different way yeah congratulations again
on 20 years you guys are obviously doing
something right and you guys must be
really nice cool guys because your guest
hosts keep coming back they keep coming
back for more so vinnie is coming back
in just a few weeks how does it feel to
have him you know joining the cast again
man we love vinnie and we love these
vinnie shows and the fans are always
wild um yeah and his uh last run was an
incredible success or uh yeah the
turnout was amazing so he's back on may
27th and we couldn't be more excited
well until then you can get your
chippendales fixed you can come down
here hang out at the booth these guys
will be here until about six o'clock
tonight but throughout the time while
this booth is here you'll have different
cast members that are actually hanging
out taking pictures and sean i just got
to ask you you are all around the city
these days one minute i see you carrying
a puppy at the animal foundation event
the next moment you're you know
escorting lisa vanderpump how does it
feel to really just be part of this
vegas community um it feels very very
good to be a part of this vegas
community i've been here for just over
18 well about 18 years and this is my
life i grew up in entertainment and to
be doing that here and making my
presence known here and
you know to be a part of the legacy of
vegas you know as a chippenhall as you
know performing the other shows i've
performed and too it just feels really
amazing to be a part of that yeah well
we're happy to have all you guys here
and also something fun going on out here
you're doing a cool ticket giveaway is
that right we are yes so every day for
the entire month of may we are giving
away a couple of free tickets to
randomly randomly down here once a day
so come down get your photo taken and uh
and see if you can win a couple tickets
to the show wow you guys are always
doing something fun out here the photo
booth is awesome it's located close to
the strip on las vegas boulevard here
but lots of fun things to do on the
promenade so be sure to stop by get a
picture and you know i can't i can't
wrap this up without a little something
to tease our crowd can we can we see a
t-shirt rip or something sean let's do
it yeah i'm putting you on the spot here
here we go
there we go i'm obviously having a lot
of fun down here i'll send it back to
you guys jillian i think i think